in chimera you can animate structure
translations and rotations in xyz
changes in the representation of ribbons
and atoms changes in opacity and color
and more in this tutorial we will
explore some of these capabilities by
creating a short animation with the
hemoglobin structure 4 hhb
before we begin to animate it is
important to obtain the correct
dimensions for the graphics window if
you're uploading to youtube you'll want
your dimensions to be of the ratio 1280
by 720. to set this ratio for the
graphics window type into the command
line window size all one word space 1280
space 720 and press enter
now this is a relatively small window to
work in so feel free to scale up the
dimensions if needed for this tutorial
i'll be scaling up by a factor of 1.5
which will make the graphics window have
dimensions of 1920 by 1080
now we can go to tools
utilities and animation to access the
animation interface
we will be using this interface to
create snapshot scenes called keyframes
each containing a different depiction
state of the structure
once we arrange these keyframes in the
timeline chimera will transition
smoothly between them to create the
animation
at this point it's also worth noting
that chimera's animation runs at a rate
of 24 frames per second
this value will become an important
conversion factor later on
to create our first keyframe we'll take
a snapshot of the structure in its
default state using the green plus icon
next we're going to set up a color
change by going to actions
color all options and selectively
coloring the ribbons green
now we'll take a snapshot of the result
to create the second keyframe
it is also possible to update keyframes
once you have created them let's say
that you want to color the protein
ribbon something other than green
to do this we first make the desired
change and then right click on the
corresponding keyframe and select update
now that keyframe contains the change
made in the graphics window
for our final scene we are going to zoom
into a heme group by first selecting
chain b
then changing the selection mode to
intersect
and finally selecting heme
then under actions we can focus in
on the heme group
clear the selection
and take another snapshot to create the
final keyframe
it is now time to begin arranging the
keyframes in the timeline
to do this we drag them in one by one
notice the number that appears at the
bottom as we drag them in
that number denotes the number of frames
currently contained in the animation
recalling that chimera runs at a rate of
24 frames per second we see that the
current duration is about 3 seconds
by right clicking on the keyframe and
selecting properties
we can set the transition length
precisely
this value denotes the number of frames
between the current and preceding
keyframes
now the color change will take exactly
three seconds to complete
similarly we will allow three seconds
for the zoom transition by again going
to properties and then setting the frame
number to 72.
in the timeline the three keyframes are
equally spaced in accordance with our
frame number settings
finally we can add a 360 degree rotation
to the animation by dragging the roll
action into the timeline we don't want
the rotation to be too fast though so we
will allow seven seconds by going to
properties and setting the frame number
to 168.
now we are ready to export the animation
to do this we click the red and grey
record button
now we can give our animation a suitable
name such as 4-hb dash animation
next we need to select the file format
here i'll go with the default h.264.mp4
finally we hit record and wait for the
animation to render
with the export complete we can now view
the finished animation
you